♪ ♪
>> Greg: DEMOCRATS UNDER
PRESSURE TO BLOCK
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LATEST CABINET
NOMINEES.
CIA CHIEF MIKE POMPEO TO BE THE
NEXT SECRETARY OF STATE.
CIA VET GINA HASPEL TO LEAD THAT
AGENCY.
THE PRESSURES COMING FROM
LEFT-WING ACTIVISTS, THE PEOPLE
WE NEED TO DECIDE WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
I JOKE.
ASKING A LEFTY FOR SUGGESTIONS
ON NATIONAL SECURITY IS LIKE
ASKING A CONSERVATIVE FOR TIPS
ON VEGAN RESTAURANTS.
IT'S NOT OUR WHEELHOUSE.
I DON'T BLAME THEM.
THIS IS WHAT IDEOLOGUES DO WHEN
THEY ARE OUT OF POWER PRETTY
PLAY DEFENSE.
IT'S PETTY TO BLOCK NOMINATIONS
BUT WHEN IT'S ALL YOU'VE GOT,
IT'S ALL YOU'VE GOT.
REPUBLICANS HAVE DONE IT TOO BUT
THIS IS DIFFERENT.
THIS IS NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHEN REPUBLICANS BLOCKED, THEY
USUALLY HAVE STRONGER
ALTERNATIVES TO FILL THOSE
SPOTS, NOT WIMPY OR WANTS.
IF THE RIGHT HATES YOUR CHOICES
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY, IT'S
BECAUSE THEY KNOW NATIONAL
SECURITY.
SO WE GOT ASKED, WHAT IS YOUR
ALTERNATIVE?
THAT WON'T PLEASE -- CHELSEA
MANNING TO HEAD THE CIA?
BILL ERRORS FOR SECRETARY OF
STATE.
I EXAGGERATE BECAUSE IT'S FUN.
WHENEVER A LEFT-WINGER SUGGESTS
WILL BE TOOTHLESS.
NATIONAL SECURITY MAKES HIM
WINCE.
WHEN YOU BELIEVE ENHANCED
INTERROGATION IS REALLY MEAN TO
BAD PEOPLE WHO AREN'T REALLY BAD
AT ALL BECAUSE THEY ARE JUST
VICTIMS OF AMERICA'S OPPRESSIVE
FOREIGN POLICY, YOU SHOULD
PROBABLY GO AWAY.
LET THE ADULTS HANDLE THIS.
IT'S A FACT.
DANA, NATIONAL SECURITY, IT'S
THE REPUBLICANS DOMAIN.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD SIT IT OUT.
CALL US WHEN IT'S DONE.
>> Dana: BUT WE NEED THEIR
VOTES.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
THEY COULD MAIL IN THE VOTES.
ABSENTEE.
REPUBLICANS ARE TERRIBLE WITH
BIG GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE TERRIBLE WITH FOREIGN
POLICY.
>> Dana: THEY ARE PASSING A
BILL TODAY THAT WILL SPEND A
TRILLION DOLLARS.
FOR GINA HASPEL, THIS IS GOING
TO BE A TOUGH CONFIRMATION.
THERE WERE NO WAR CRIMES.
THERE WAS NOTHING ILLEGAL.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE IF THERE HAVE BEEN, I
GUARANTEE YOU FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC HOLDER
WOULD HAVE PROSECUTED HER AND
OTHERS.
THREE ATTORNEYS GENERAL HAVE
LOOKED AT THIS.
THEY HAVE NOT TAKEN ANY ACTION.
THE PROBLEM IS GREG, THERE'S NO
LOGIC OR REASONING WITH PEOPLE
ON THIS ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT CHOSE TO HAVE TO
HAVE A FIGHT ON THIS
CONFIRMATION.
HE COULD HAVE GONE WITH SOMEBODY
THAT DIDN'T REQUIRE SPENDING A
LOT OF POLITICAL CAPITAL AND ALL
THE PAIN AND AGONY IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO GET HER CONFIRMED.
BUT ANYWAY, I WONDER IF THE
PRESIDENT'S THINKING HE WANTS
THIS FIGHT.
FOR THE POINT YOU MADE ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Greg: KIMBERLY, BLOCKING
NOMINATIONS, THAT'S WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOU'RE OUT OF POWER.
YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH ELSE TO DO.
>> Kimberly: THAT IS TOTALLY
LAME.
IF I WERE GINA HASPEL, I WOULD
MAKE SURE THEY WERE GOING TO
NOMINATE ME.
I WOULD FACE ALL THOSE MEN AND
SAY WATERBOARD ME.
I WILL SHOW YOU IT'S NOT SO BAD.
SHE STANDS BY HER RECORD.
SHE'S INCREDIBLY CAPABLE.
SHE'S VERY TOUGH.
SHE'S SMART.
SHE'S AUTHENTIC.
SHE'S GENUINE.
SHE'S NOT A HYPOCRITE.
THEY'D BE LUCKY TO HAVE HER.
I THINK IT'S FANTASTIC.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GAIN BY
TRYING TO BLOCK A WOMAN AND
FIGHT THESE BATTLES.
THEY HAVE BEEN TERM ELECTIONS
COMING.
SOME OF THE PROJECTIONS ARE NOT
LOOKING GOOD FOR YOUR TEAM,
JUAN, WHATSOEVER.
>> Juan: MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
>> Kimberly: I THINK SO, YES.
THE REPUBLICANS MIGHT PICK UP
THREE SEATS.
WAIT AND SEE, JUAN.
YOU ARE GOING TO BE CRYING IN
YOUR SOUP.
>> Greg: HE DOES LIKE SOUP.
JUAN, HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
BEING CONNECTED TO SUCH A SEXIST
PARTY THAT WOULD REJECT A WOMAN
TO BE THE FIRST HEAD OF THE CIA?
SHOULDN'T YOU BE WITH HER?
I AM WITH HER.
SHOULDN'T HILLARY BE WITH HER.
>> Juan: YES, YES, YES.
I THINK YOU WERE WITH HER WHEN
SHE WAS DESTROYING THE TAPES.
OR MAYBE YOU WERE WITH HER -- I
THINK GIVEN THE FACT THAT SHE
NEEDS DEMOCRATIC VOTES BECAUSE
OF RAND PAUL, McCAIN IS NOT
THERE.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING LIKE
SPECIFICALLY HAVE HER SIT THERE
AND SAY I RENOUNCE THE USE OF
TORTURE.
I UNDERSTAND IS IN A MATTER OF
CONSCIENCE FOR US AS AMERICANS.
THIS IS NOT WHO WE ARE AS THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO DO IT.
>> Kimberly: RAND PAUL IS A
GREAT VOTE COUNTER.
HE WOULDN'T DO THAT IF HE DIDN'T
KNOW THEY WERE GOING TO GET RED
STATE DEMOCRATS TO SUPPORT HER.
>> Juan: YOU CAN SAY THAT
ABOUT POMPEO BUT I DON'T THINK
YOU CAN SAY AT ABOUT GINA
HASPEL.
IT'S AN ISSUE OF TORTURING
PEOPLE LEFT AND RIGHT WHO ARE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Jesse: LISTENING TO JUAN IS
TORTURE.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT A WAR ON
WOMEN, LET'S GO.
HIS >> Juan: LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
YOU ARE USING HER GENDER TO
DEFEND HER?
>> Greg: WHERE DID YOU GET
THIS IDEA FROM?
WHERE DID IT COME FROM?
IS SHE NATIVE AMERICAN?
>> Juan: IN OTHER WORDS, --
>> Jesse: MAKING THE ARGUMENT
WE HAVE MADE AT THIS TABLE.
>> Juan: WHEN YOU ARE
ATTACKING HILLARY.
>> Jesse: NO, JUAN, I AM
PLAYING THE GENDER CARD THAT
YOU --
>> Juan: WHAT GENDER CARD?
>> Jesse: SHE IS THE TOUGHEST
WOMAN WHO HAS EVER SERVED.
SHE WAS OVERSEEING AN
INTERROGATION AT A BLACK SITE
AND YOU THINK SHE IS TOO TOUGH
ON TERROR.
LET'S HAVE THAT FIGHT.
LET'S HAVE IT.
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT TOUGH ON